it is my pleasure to introduce my
colleague Andy Prado Andy is the
director of the program on geopolitics
technology and governance at the
Stanford cyber Policy Center he's also a
William J Perry international security
fellow at the Freeman spogli Institute
and visiting fellow at the Hoover
Institution
Andy was formerly a senior director for
cyber policy on the National Security
Council in both the Obama and the Trump
administrations and before that served
as a professional staff member for the
Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
Andy also leads the cyber specialization
curriculum for the Ford Dorsey masters
international policy program at FSI
where he teaches the core fundamentals
course on cyber policy his research is
in the vortex of cyber security national
security and the economics of tech and
innovation and he has had involved
involvement in virtually every major
policy policy debate over the last 10
years spamming his experience with
Congress the executive branch and in
academia so I'm so happy to turn it over
to him and jump in to preview this
executive education that we are gonna
run in August and we hope you can join
us right thanks Danielle welcome to
everyone it's a pleasure to to join you
all this morning or afternoon as the
case may be for some of you from from
further flung places then then the bay
area I hope you and your families are
safe and 7yz unusual and trying times so
I wanted to goals for our webinar today
one is to give for a short course
overview for the executive education
program that we're planning to run in
August and then I want to give you kind
of an amuse-bouche an appetizer on what
some of the course content look like in
this case I want to focus in particular
on this question of attribution which
ends up consuming a lot of media
attention a lot of policy focus and I
want to provide sort of an analytic
framework for business leaders and
leaders and public organizations for how
to think about attribution decisions
before I get into the course overview I
know that you know there's a lot of
questions still what will won't be open
as far as shelter-in-place goes our
assumption is that this course will run
in August we still have spots available
so I if you're interested our plan so
far is all system you go so with that
let me we jump into the course overview
so you know there's a saying among among
cyber nerds like me that you know
there's for two types of organizations
or organizations that in but know that
they have been hacking organizations
that have been hacked
in other words data breaches cyber
security incidents are almost inevitable
in this day and age and this what you
see in front of you is a the results of
a survey that the UK government did
business is this is in the UK
specifically but I think the results are
pretty applicable worldwide that in
their survey basically one-third of
businesses experienced a breach or an
attack in the last 12 months and and you
can see what impact it had on their
business operations you know with with
pending staff from carrying out the work
functions consuming resources that could
be spent on pursuing mission objectives
building a business and so on headlines
I mean if you read a newspaper even this
morning there's a New York Times about a
new cyber attack attributed by an
Israeli research group to the Chinese
military the pandemic has become a
source of exploitation for malicious
actors who are using the pandemic both
to Spearfish right trick people into
opening up emails with malicious
attachments related to Cove in 19
preying on their preying on their fears
to try to hack their systems there's
also a lot of
ransomware attacks its businesses and
other organizations
last Friday President Trump declared a
national emergency as based on evidence
that that foreign hackers were seeking
to infiltrate the u.s. power grid and
then of course you know the FBI has seen
a major spike in cyber crime reports
during this pandemic this is just you
know the last you know month or so
you'll see that that you know among
boards cyber security is top of mind the
World Economic Forum does this survey of
business leaders every year and this is
the most recent report you'll see that
the cyber attacks are you know
essentially and a defect and fraud or
among the highest impact and highest
probability risks that that are top of
mind for them at the same time this this
is a report from another survey that
that Marsh and Microsoft did where you
see that that across time cyber risks
outrank all other risks by a wide margin
and the question posed to the
respondents was of the following
business threats please rank the top
five and the biggest concerns your
organization and you'll see that percent
listed cyberattacks in the top five with
almost a quarter of them identifying
cyber risk as the D number one risk now
what's worrisome about this is that even
as the awareness of the threat is
growing the scale and scope of the
threat is expanding leaders the
confidence in their ability to manage
this set of risks is actually declining
and so you'll see here that you know
that essentially there's one confidence
among business leaders that there they
are the organizations are in a position
to understand assess measure cyber
threats to
to prevent cyber threats or manage and
respond to cyber threats that to me is
really worrying I think it shows a real
gap between the growing magnitude of the
threat and our confidence in our
business leaders policymakers and their
ability to to manage this this new this
growing and complex risk meanwhile you
know this were only becoming more and
more reliant on on a digital world for
our daily lives this is a story that's
probably familiar to most but you know
as we move to a world the biggest
connectivity sensing processing the
attack service the number of devices on
the Internet will grow our reliance on
computers and networks will grow and
just to put that into perspective this
this is some statistics from how DC that
that shows that by 2025 just the sheer
volume of Internet of Things connections
will increase that factor of about four
or five just just you know the next five
five or so years now meanwhile
policymakers had been you know focused
on cyber tickling the u.s. was involved
in a lot of these debates as Daniel said
I drew my time the government and the
pace is only quickly and so I just put
up here you know smattering of recent
headlines on different regulatory and
legislative initiatives around the world
that are being trying to address cyber
risks and these policy interventions are
primarily aimed at the private sector
and have potential for major impact on
business operations and so you know and
the actors involved range from
California a US state to the European
Union China the US federal government so
so let me now turn directly to to the
the course with that with that
background the overarching goal
the program will be to close that
confident status today I identified by
delivering foundational knowledge on
cyber risk cyber policy and resilience
to to our students so we'll cover the
tech basics and we'll adjust how deep we
go depending on what the complexion of
the the student cadre looks like but we
don't assume any technical expertise on
the part of students and if we happen to
get students with deep technical
expertise we'll have some room to make
adjustments to the curriculum based on
what the complexion of the class looks
like
we'll cover the fundamentals of cyber
risk management will cover threat actors
their motivations I will cover
regulatory policy Incident Response and
statecraft in the international aspects
of cyber policy cyber risk how we'll
cover it
they'll be lectures we're assembling I
think a pre crack team of instructors
with experience both with practical
experience as well as experience talking
about cyber issues in a clear and
intelligible way we'll we'll lean on
group work to get the students
interacting with each other learning
from each other and we'll do scenario
exercises and so you'll bring your track
suit your Walkman I love doing exercises
I find that that your simulations are a
really powerful way to help bring
content home I want to make one point
about about the content that you know so
there's this difference between
education and training right so training
is about learning to do a particular
task education is about building a
foundation this this is about education
so we're not our goal is not to provide
sort of a regimented step-by-step
approach to if you suffer a cyber
incident or if you know the US Congress
is pursuing a legislative initiative
upon X here's what you do that that's
not that's not what we want to do we
want to provide the foundation so that
students can can cover and manage teams
across different all these different
cyber and problems that that come up in
business in the public policy and so
that end our students we have in mind
our executives and leadership roles or
seeking such roles where literacy and
cyber risk policy are essential to
mission success so with that let's jump
into attribution whodunnit you know this
is probably a little bit of a
generational thing
I love watching Murder She Wrote I was
an American TV show with Angela Lansbury
actually never been English apologies to
any any UK call but you know involved
you know she was a writer who who solved
murder mysteries I realize murder
mysteries and you know it speaks to this
instinct that when when something when a
crime happens our sort of collective
consciousness media narrative
policymakers business leaders towards
all want to know who did this bad act
who did it the natural question I think
incur a whole lot for things like
holding malicious actors accountable for
deterrence imposing costs on on
perpetrators but you know the media and
policy in public discourse on
attribution tends to frame this issue a
little too simplistic we for my tastes
as in fact a public attribution in other
words there's this binary choice
supposedly you know in a lot of the the
narrative about cyber risk management
that organizations have a choice between
public attribution and no attribution
and I I think that's wrong and and I
want to you know leave you with some
thoughts on that my goal is to dispel
that notion provide leaders in business
and government with a vocabulary and
framework for thinking about how to
communicate about cyber incidents that
affect them or their stakeholders so I
want to introduce a couple concepts two
overarching concepts I'm an analytic
solution and strategic attribution
attribution you can think of as who do
we think did it it's based on what
knows or thinks he or she knows about
the identity of a malicious cyber actor
it's often based on forensic and other
technical artifacts but not necessarily
limited to that type of technical detail
the other day it's a falsifiable claim
who perpetrated an attack strategic
attribution is okay so you've got you've
got this theory of whodunit what now do
you do with that and there are at least
four options that I want to leave you
with one is what I call private
contribution you could keep it you can
keep that analytic judgment private
selective attribution you could disclose
that judgment to selected third parties
public attribution you could you can
make your judgment about attribution
public and then of course this is my
favorite one the false flag attribution
where you purposefully misattribute in
some strategic way so you you may even
have a theory of whodunit but you you
know pin the blame on someone else for
some purpose the key take away from this
this vocabulary and this way of sort of
breaking down this concert with
attribution is that decisions about
strategic attribution are or should be
guided by political and economic factors
pertaining to which mode of strategic
attribution most advances the
decision-makers interest and so in other
words a decision about what to do with
an analytic attribution is not a
technical decision is a management and
leadership decision I don't rate this
point with with with this a few kind of
made-up examples that have some you may
recognize you know some of the
characters in these then yes I'm going
to share with you but you know the names
have been changed to protect the
innocent plus I just need to talk about
it so first here we have a company Acme
widget company you know publicly traded
company suffered cyber-enabled theft of
its trade secrets the executive team
assesses that malicious cyber actors
located in the territory of to Korea
acting on the staff of a state owned
company
there we're behind this incident the
assessment is based in part on forensic
data but also the timing of the event
coincide with negotiations with NCC over
a joint venture to court in troika
so in this case that we had analytically
attributed the attack to NCC it's a lie
than it would have judgment about who
done another another sort of spin on
that so they're taking this okay so now
we have a country you know a public
organization a malicious is a rule of
law watching democracy and the
anglo-american tradition sounds familiar
uh Eukarya also familiar is a fledgling
democracy has its unresolved border
dispute with Rosaria adversary of a
Mauritius intelligence service in a
Mauritius disseminates a classified
intelligence Usman's internally to a
Mauritius policymakers that the actors
behind this attack are likely affiliated
with a rosarian intelligence unit this
assessment is based on foreign
intelligence collection and forensic
data brought back to a mauritius by a
flying team of a marriage I'm Irish
government experts invited by Eukarya to
support its forensic analysis of attack
this is another case of analytic
attribution dd these a malicious
government has come to an analytic
judgment about whodunit so let's let's
talk about these in a little more detail
so in these examples
speech protagonist has formulated a
judgment about analytic attribution and
for now at least they come back pipe
they've drawn on different data sources
to arrive there analytic attributions so
ask me is executive team for example
based its analytic judgment on
information from the company systems but
also their business instincts
while the a Mauritius intelligence
service drew upon intelligence sources
and methods along with this trust
relationship it's hatched with you carry
the permitted its experts to gain some
first-hand insights into the attack in
these examples the protagonists
confidence level in their an alert
judgment can be expressed in different
ways and so in the case of an richest
you know you know assuming you know that
this is a professional intelligence
service right there would there would be
really expressed clear language about
its confidence level high medium low in
its attribution assessment I mean this
this assessment this confidence level is
a function of how specific and direct
the intelligence is right and so the
extent of course that intelligence is
valuable and potentially fragile for
example you know volved sig n or some
other sensitive intelligence an aperture
the originators unban intelligence will
have strong incentives to prevent to
compartmentalize and limit the
distribution of that intelligence to
only those who need to know now what's
important to note is analytic
attribution this this this this internal
judgment about whodunit
can provoke or inform action this often
gets lost to get a lot of the public
debate about cyber risk management cyber
policy coming to a private judgment
about analytic attribution is not
necessarily consequence-free in actors
willingness to take potentially costly
actions based on an analytic attribution
speaks volumes about confidence level in
the accuracy of the attribution and in
both of these cases you know this this
private this this analytic attribution
could have a real impact on on decision
on their internal decisions so in the
case attacked me it could decide you
know what like maybe we're not going to
do business anymore in scoria or the
minimum maybe we're gonna break off our
negotiations with NCC in the case of a
malicious you know this this could be
tit to reprioritize it's it's
intelligence collection and have other
impacts on its relationship with both
Eukarya and sorry now by the same token
i think to note that that some defensive
actions don't even require attribution
right yeah so a defender does not in
some cases necessarily mean to know the
identity of an adversary
to implement known trendabl influences
and you know just despite you know the
the interest and whodunit in many many
cases defenders don't need to know that
in order to do their job and but yeah
that said of course there are there are
times when it does help defenders to
know who did it because we could help
set learning the identity of the defense
of the attacker and their motivations
can help the defender set mitigation
priorities and more effectively assess
risk so let's let's turn now to a couple
examples which PG graduation so here we
have acne again it's CISO decides to
share information about the incident
along with the company's analytic
attribution to a trusted circle of
fellow scissors at similarly situated
companies to help them and also to
reinforce reciprocity norms among this
community of scissors about sharing
threat information within this circle of
trust they share the information under
this this this information sharing
rubric called a traffic light protocol
I'll say a little bit more about that to
highlight a sensitive sensitivity of
information right traffic light protocol
red is a way to say this is sensitive
information
you know don't don't disclose without
getting further permission from from
from the originator and then the company
General Council also shares information
about the incident with outside counsel
to understand legal risks and notifies a
malicious law enforcement so in this
case ask me has selectively attributed
the attack to NCC and by selective it is
not engaged in a public attribution it
is selectively shared it's analytical
attribution with with certainly third
parties let's go back to a Mauritius in
this case a Mauritius provides
classified threat briefings to major a
Mauritius grid operators about this
attack and in the classified briefing
the a Mauritius government described
it's it's classified oolitic attribution
of Rosaria as the perpetrator this
context to reinforce the severity of the
need for the operators to prioritize
these particular mitigations the
briefers also hope that the quality of
the briefing including the decision to
share sensitive forensic attribution
details will persuade the operators to
reciprocate and engage in information
sharing with americium about the threat
and what they see on their networks and
so in this case the a malicious
government has selectively attributed
the attack to Azaria with major grid
operators as the recipients of the
selective attribution so let's let's
talk about these two cases a little more
so in this case
[Music]
so the ambitious briefers chip analytic
attribution with a subset of critical
infrastructure owners and operators on a
protect public safety they made a
judgment that that in this case the Amer
and a nourishes interests were best
served by engaging in selective
attribution short of public contribution
you know
blasts in a press release saying we
think that this or that country did it
now what we've got to think about is by
being so selective in its outreach to
the private sector a Mauritius has now
assumed new risks so what if Rosaria or
another malicious actor was able to use
substantially similar tradecraft to
attack sectors that hadn't been breached
of course most importantly this would
put the people of a Mauritius at risk of
harm but it could also jeopardize the
political fortunes of a Marisa's
leadership who in the aftermath of such
an attack would face the inevitable
second guessing of why they had failed
to brief more companies the so what does
and there's a question of okay what does
Eukarya think about a Mauritius actions
and emerges there you know I mean
after all Eukarya is not likely to learn
a foreign government even a friendly one
examine infrastructure that was targeted
by a hostile foreign power or without
some guarantee that the fruits of that
examination would make their way back to
Acharya and so one of the issues that
the a Mauritius and Eukarya and their
respective legal advisers would want to
have worked through in advance is
calibrating both sides expectations
about what is and it's not shared by way
of intelligence associated with the
incident you know what what you know
based since a Mauritius head is flying
team come in
you know there's now this you know the
attribution is tied in some way to this
relationship with Eukarya
cameras could share its technical
findings with your Caria but leave it up
to Yukari to connect the attribution the
analytic attribution dots or if we go a
step further and engage acharya in a
more robust limit exchange and dialogue
it could include judgments about
analytic attribution either way the two
parties and we're gonna want to think
about this in advance so coming to acne
so the executives are trying to get
their heads around what happened by
seeking external advice assistance the
scissor recognizing that peer InfoSec
officers and similar companies might be
facing similar risks and the contact of
TLP so TLP is widely used by endless
tech practitioners to lay the thread
information relating to its perceived
sensitivity and essentially as a request
to handle the information with that
sensitivity in mind typically red is the
highest classification under the scheme
means that material is not for
disclosure and restricted only to the
immediate recipients of that information
that kind of exchange happens all the
time in the corporate InfoSec world and
and at least the anecdotal evidence I've
seen suggests that these exchanges
result in stronger defenses on the other
hand these exchanges often occur without
the knowledge or consent of the
company's senior executives these
exchanges tend to be informal rooted in
personal bonds of trust and done with
some level of secrecy and so in this
case the fact that information is
labeled TLP red means that that the
information that we Acme Suzhou
shared shouldn't be you know sure even
you know beyond the immediate recipient
so that will include other parts of the
organization's who the recipients belong
to clean their senior executives
that's important to note that that the
TLP scheme is not binding on
participants putting putting a TLP
classification on a document or
asserting it in a conversation does not
create any legal rights or duties among
the parties to the exchange so unless
the recipient sign non-disclosure
agreements or some other agreement or
specific law is broken we would have no
recourse under the law to sue or press
charges against recipient who violates
the terms of t.o.p read sharing as
example indicates ask me isn't a witty
business and assuming it's a
conscientious well-managed business the
company's management team will work
closely or when it says oh and legal
counsel you're gonna get to get an
accurate handle on on what information
within the company was exposed in the
breach and what courses it must then
pursue by way of mitigation and
resilience was it just information CC or
was other information exposed such as
trade secrets or customer data to the
extent that that customer data was
exposed as a company being to notify its
customers under the law or for business
reputation reasons and if so does it
disclose this analytic attribution in
other words engage in selective
attribution as a publicly traded company
are there any market disclosures it
needs to make under a Mauritius
securities law is the company's analytic
attribution of the incident to NCC
materially relevant to the market
implications of the breach it could be
to the extent that the breach affects
the company's plans in Korea so less
than at least and I wrap up here in just
a few minutes and we'll turn to Q&A is
take a music stand these examples one
step further so here now okay so ask me
would you companies not decide to file a
lawsuit
never Asia's court against NCC for fact
trade secrets and other damages in its
pleadings
now Acme has publicly attributed the
attack to NSYNC
you know it's it's went through this
process okay they reached an analytic
judgment about analytic attribution who
done it they decided to initially to
engage in selective attribution sharing
it with a select group of third parties
now they decided that their interests
are best served by by filing a lawsuit
against an scene for theft of trade
secrets and other damages they have now
publicly attributed the attack to NCC
[Music]
turning to a Mauritius
the ministers of energy homeland
security and state issued joint
statement implicating accusing Azaria
for the attack and the ministers and
other law enforcement colleagues publish
and a lot of the technical aspects the
public alert with recommended mitigation
steps meanwhile the Ministry of Justice
in Deitz three operators in the reserve
a military intelligence service for
criminal prosecution and the ministries
of Commerce and Treasury imposed
sanctions and so on now of course here
the a Mauritius government is publicly
attributing the attack to azaria through
through several channels the key I think
point about this last you know these
sort of lasts yet is that okay so we're
public attribution now we began with an
internal assessment of whodunit there's
a lot of action that happened between
analytic attribution and this at least
acts of public attribution business
leaders an acne which accompanied the a
Mauritius government had a range of
options between analytic judge analytics
attribution and public contribution you
know they could engage they can decide
to keep their analytic judgment private
they could decide to engage which which
they might do they could decide to
engage in selective attribution a
decision to close a dislike and third
parties they can gauge and public
attribution taken we didn't go talk too
much about
false flag attribution yeah just list
here completeness but they can decide to
cue someone else the key point here is
that the decisions in just a rap kind of
come full circle ultimately decisions
about strategic attribution should be
guided by political and economic factors
pertaining to which mode of strategic
attribution most advances the
decision-makers interest it is not
simply or strictly a technical judgment
about whodunit and in fact judgment
about who done it may include
intelligence and business instincts that
that go beyond technical artifacts at
the end of the day strategic attribution
is fundamentally a decision for
executives to make and shouldn't be left
to shouldn't should be treated as such
by by senior management whether it's a
private organization or or in government
I can I can tell you that that was
certainly how we handle issues of this
this question why was at the NSC and
there were many many many many cases
where you know we the US government had
an attribution about who who done it
but the question of what to do with it
was always a policy decision and guided
by political and economic factors so I
will stop there I would like to thank
you Andy so much webinar I think what's
really interesting I don't know if
daniel has anything else you would like
to add in the end
no no okay so I think we are all good
thank you everybody for joining us today
I hope you will spend rest from what's
today Thursday and have a nice weekend
thank you take everyone be safe